you're doing stand up and it feels to me
and this is something I've said a lot
over the years I've said the trick of
this business isn't to figure out some
new person that you should be who's
funny or resonates with people the trick
is to figure out who you always were
and then do that
in a weird situation which means lights
cameras people around and you know here
she is Leslie Jones music you come out
that is a very unnatural environment
it's very in some ways very fake but you
gotta crack how can I be the person I
was who killed at all those parties with
your friends and that's what you do you
go into the search of
who's oh ah Leslie is the one that's
funny not these people that you've been
like I would rip a room and someone
would come up to me and go oh my God
you're so [ __ ] funny oh my God you're
one of the funniest people I've ever
seen and I would be like ah I'm good I'm
okay and she they would be like but what
the [ __ ] was and I was like well you
know I'm not Richard Pryor yeah and
they'd be like well I don't [ __ ] like
what you're probably like you like give
yourself some love like cause I like you
I've never seen Richard so I just saw
you and I had to stop myself from doing
that you know I had to go okay so it's
you up here telling these jokes is you
writing these jokes so it's you also
adulation doesn't get you anywhere right
so if you you know I spent so many years
you know thinking I have no right to
even be in the same room as all these
incredibly funny people that I admire
that doesn't take you anywhere that
leaves you cold yeah there you know
they're great they're great but it's
isolating and it cuts the creative
process off and in a way way you have to
figure out okay yes they're great
they're amazing but I got to put that
away right now and figure out who I am
and if someone likes that great maybe we
can get something going and it's but
like it's just the same thing it's like
Kobe is Kobe's good as Michael well
Michael was Michael Kobe was Kobe you
know what I'm saying so it's in that
same fact like I was just telling my
friend I was like I wonder if we're
gonna have to start letting go of the
Whitney Houston's and the Michael
Jackson's and the princes and the
admiration for them so we just let room
in for these new artists I just went and
saw Bruno Mars and Anderson pack like
two of the most that was the most
incredible concert I've ever seen and
they are so talented but I'm so scared
No One's Gonna know that this talented
until too late right you know like we
got to give them some love you're right
now they're creating great things yes
Prince was incredible yes Michael
Jackson was incredible yes Whitney
Houston was [ __ ] incredible like but
we gotta start we gotta support the
people who are here now who was
incredible now like who's incredible now
like because if if that's the case then
we go all the way back and say Marvin
Gaye was the best singer ever you know
what I'm saying like now we don't go
anywhere yeah
we don't move exactly exactly exactly
and that's what's wrong with us this
whole world right now is that we just
we're so absolutely frightened to move
the [ __ ] on yeah we're so goddamn
frightened and it don't make no damn
sense because if we don't move on we are
going to die what do you think we're
frightened of we're frightened of change
yeah we don't understand that we've
already been changing if we hadn't
changed we would all be dead from
dysentery do you get what the [ __ ] I'm
saying yeah I mean it's just amazing to
me how we're not believing science how
we would not believe in our advancement
how how I was in the airport and we were
in this little trolley that takes you
around the airport and it's [ __ ]
brick wall I was like we can build this
[ __ ] but we don't believe in vaccines
yeah
make it make [ __ ] sense and and for
us to now just all of a sudden a
profession that we [ __ ] hold so high
we don't even believe the doctors no
more what the [ __ ] is wrong with us what
the [ __ ] is wrong with this and and I
feel like social media has been a
blessing and a curse in that because
they've given everybody a platform yes
people who who and I love you people but
some of y'all don't need to talk
I love you to death but some of y'all
need to keep your [ __ ] opinion and
your goddamn kitchen yeah yeah sometimes
people say don't say that [ __ ] out loud
some of y'all need to put that on your
[ __ ] door yeah and just keep your
[ __ ] to yourself son that there's a
reason that we don't say everything on
our mind yeah there's a reason that you
have sensors there's a reason you know
the idea initially when social media
first came along is this is going to
bring us all together and then the great
irony is that everybody's completely
isolated because if I don't like you
know Leslie if I don't like your opinion
or I don't like what you're saying I
never have to see you or hear you
because I can modify everything in my
life
only see one I've tried uh no
and you were never blocked me
a [ __ ] show up but no but it's it's
true she wasn't even invited on this
podcast
you're not supposed to be here today I
just came crashing through the door you
just punched Henry Winkler and came
running in
him too but no it is it is so uh crazy
to me that everyone can just take a bath
in their own opinions and their own
ideas and never be challenged and never
be checked yeah that that's
accountability is just what everyone
needs to learn accountability even down
to driving like I was driving the other
day and you know Melrose is [ __ ] up
because of the construction right okay
so everybody's trying to get along
everybody's like okay we're gonna make
[ __ ] do with this one [ __ ]
that needs to pull over to the side and
[ __ ] back up in the middle of the
[ __ ] traffic but no one says anything
no one's bopping their horns no one's
saying [ __ ] no police there
checking so you're gonna do what the
[ __ ] you want that's exactly what's
going on now no one's getting checked
because everybody's so sensitive no one
knows how to say sit your [ __ ]
ass down because oh we're not supposed
to say that yes you are that it's a it's
a thing that's going on now where people
are not falling down you need to fall
down so you can get back up people are
not scratching their knee I want to
scratch everybody's knee do you get what
I'm saying you mean you you think people
need to people try [ __ ] hurt yeah you
need to people have this thing right now
where oh you owe people y'all glamorize
suffering no [ __ ] ass [ __ ] we
glamorize being strong we glamorize
learning a [ __ ] lesson we glamorize
hey if you make a [ __ ] mistake you
made a mistake get your ass up and
[ __ ] either fix it or keep it moving
right we don't learn oh we made a
mistake everybody hug each other no
you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
up tell somebody they [ __ ] up you're
wrong that's wrong that's bad you know
it's interesting you just said
I've noticed this recently nobody says
anymore all right I was wrong I never
hear that and you used to have to hear
it because the analysis would come out
the election would be over the results
would come in and someone would go well
okay I was wrong I thought I was going
to win but I didn't now people that run
for office say if I didn't win it was
because it was fixed but if I do win
then it was still kind of fixed but I
still won anyway
yeah and so I think you're right I I'm
in my life in my personal life when I
walk around if anybody says you know
what I made a mistake and I'm sorry
I think that person's a genius like I I
have so much respect for it and it
completely changes the way I see them
and the way I feel about them and for
[ __ ] say my bad yo I I give
messages man my bad yo i i people who
project
you know uh it's a lot of projection we
have a passive aggressive is the new
thing now you know yeah read between the
lines I'm saying what the [ __ ] I really
mean but I'm not saying what I really
mean right you know and it's it's it's
disgusting it's like we're in other
words fake it till you make it it's
making [ __ ] float do you know what I'm
saying back in the day when you used to
say a fake it too I make it that means
that I'm going to fake it until I really
actually learn what the [ __ ] I'm gonna
do now it means I'm just gonna fake it
all the way to the top